Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
authored by
in the fifth chapter which is the
chapter of
is being vigilant
constantly conscious and aware care of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and his observation
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala is observing
the first narration
mentions
in this chapter is the very popular
well-known narration
of
it's collected by Muslim
It's also been narrated by Abdullahbn
Omar who narrates it from his father.
It's also been narrated by both Bkari
and Muslim on the authority of Abi.
Most of us have heard this narration.
The question here is that
when it comes to
putting down evidence, when it comes to
authoring a book and I wish to use a
verse or use a narration, especially
when it comes to narrations,
when it comes to verses, I want to use
the verse which is most immediately
bolstering the point that I'm making in
the chapter.
Right? I don't want to use a verse that
is
unclear
as an evidence for that particular thing
that I am writing on. I want to use the
most immediate
verse which leads to that conclusion
and bolsters what it is that is being
said. And when it comes to the science
of hadith,
not only do we look for the most clear
narration
which most clearly states what it is
that I'm trying to bolster and use it
as an evidence for
but also the highest
grade of authenticity I can. All right.
So for instance this narration here
or we could give an example from the
Quran.
For instance, if I wanted to
use a verse in the Quran as an
evidence that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is merciful.
I would use a verse that clearly says
this.
For instance, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
or he says subhanahua
orman
all of these are evidences which clearly
state that word that I'm looking to use
as an evidence. But that's not the only
evidence of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
mercy.
Any verse in the Quran which articulates
the meaning of mercy is also an
evidence. So for instance that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sends down the rain
upon a dead piece of land and brings it
back to life. Is that not from Allah's
mercy? Yes, of course. That is that is
the result of Allah's mercy and that is
the interaction of Allah's mercy with
his creation
but that is indirect
or it is less obvious
than the pro previous verses that we
mentioned which use the actual wording
of alma. I think that's pretty clear.
Now when it comes to narrations, this
chapter is about what? It's about
meaning the vigilance
of Allah subhanahu Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that a person is aware that Allah
is watching him that he is conscious of
the fact that Allah is listening that he
behaves in a way that someone who knows
he is being watched by the almighty
would behave this is it's a great act of
worship
Now the reason he mentions this
narration first which is the narration
of Omar I think every one of us here
knows this narration or at least knows
its meaning where Omar says a man
entered while we were sitting with the
prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam. He
had very black hair, very white
clothing. None of us recognized him nor
did he have the appearance of a
traveler. And he came in close and he
sat very close to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. He asked him what is
Islam? What is iman? What is and this is
the point of the narration here when he
said
he said
tell me about he saidan
is that you worship Allah as though he
is watching you
as though you can see him. And if you
cannot then you worship him as though
he sees you as that he sees you. And we
will get into the intricacies of this
inshallah.
But the point is is that this this
statement this sentence here this one
sentence is the reason why this very
long narration is in this chapter.
Now when I go to use a a narration as
evidence for something
I am looking for the highest level of
authenticity that's what I use as my
evidence for anything. If there is an
narration
that is in Bkari
and then there's an narration or if
there's an narration that is in for
instance
and it's also in Bkari which one am I
going to use
which which one am I going to use
Bkari right because that is a higher
level of authenticity what is the
highest level of authenticity in the
science of hadith
Huh?
Exactly the opposite. You said,
"Yeah, it's okay." They're they're
antonyms, right? Means it's differed
upon
means it's been agreed upon by both and
Muslim. That is the highest level of
authenticity. There is no higher level
of authenticity with respect to where
the narration comes from.
Now what's curious here is that this
narration as I mentioned
is collected by Bkari and Muslim but
it's not on the authority of Omar. It's
on the authority of Abi because there
were lots of companions around when this
occurrence happened when this took
place. Abu Hurayra was there, Omar was
there, many companions were there and so
many companions narrate this incident.
So we have the same narration collected
by Bkari Muslim on the authority of Abi
and then we have this narration
collected by Muslim alone on the
authority of Omar.
The question,
why would a Noahi who was a muhadith?
Why would a Noahi
use the narration
of an im Muslim
when there's another one which is the
same incident but it's by Bkari and
Muslim on the authority of why would you
do that?
We mentioned that if something is
reported by Muslim alone
and something is reported by Bkari and
Muslim which one is higher level
and Muslim
even if it's in Muslim why would you
go to what is only in Muslim and not
the narration of and that's not just the
99% of the time when you find this
incident narrated
in books of the scholars they will use
the narration of Omar which is only in
Muslim they will more rarely use the
narration of
I know that the question here in our
mind and and we will end with this is
yeah just tell us what the
narration is she and just explain it to
us so we can go on with our day. This is
this is an attitude we have to make sure
that we fight against because my job
isn't just to tell you this or that.
It's also to make you aware of where
these narrations come from. Who was Al
Bkari? Who was Muslim? How did the
scholars write their books? Why do they
write their books in these ways? These
are not this is not knowledge which
should only be the sole domain of the
scholars. This should be everyday
Muslims should know this about their
books. So back to that question, why
would a know we do that?
Anyone?
No.
Because
because it's Omar
interesting.
That's not the answer, but it is
interesting because of the narrator. But
really that doesn't matter in the
science of hadith. Why? Because
narration is not based on opinion. It's
based on what? It's based on something
that you saw and you say what you saw.
That's it. There is no opinion in it.
There's no room for opinion in it. It's
pure narration. That is why if we have a
narration
on the authority of Abu Bakr and a
narration on the authority of
on the authority of
only has one narration in all the books
of hadith. It's the same thing from the
science of hadith aspect. Why? Because
it's an issue of relating what you saw
as a witness. He witnessed something. So
what is another reason you guys think?
[Arabic recitation]
He's mentioning that the chain of
narration is shorter between
Muslim and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. When we look at chains of
narration
from chains of narration perspective,
we want the highest level of senate
because if you imagine the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is at the top
of this mountain
and the companions are a peg below him
and the below them, right? We want the
narration that has the least amount of
people between us and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. But that would be
correct if he were compiling a book on
hadith. But when it comes to using an
evidence,
that's not really the factor, the defi
determining factor. But that is a factor
in some cases Malik
has some of the highest levels
of authenticity, the shortest chains of
narration because he was before Bkari
and Muslim. But a narration
collected by Malik and a narration
collected by Bkari, we would still favor
Al Bkari because of his conditions. You
had a
Very
good. That's the answer. Yeah, that's
the answer. What is the answer?
Narration is more detailed.
Is more detailed. Why would it be more
detailed? Didn't they all witness the
same thing? Yes. But maybe Abu came into
the masid a little bit after. Or maybe
he left early. Or maybe he didn't hear
the whole thing. Or maybe when he
narrated the narration to his students,
he narrated it summarized rather than
the the the
details. I'll give you an example and we
will end with this inshallah.
Imagine someone is in a car accident.
There's a big event, right?
You pull them aside right after the car
accident.
They've still got that adrenaline in
their body. They're still right.
What will give you the most accurate
detailed account of what happened
after he's told that story 500 times or
the first time he tells that story? The
first time. All right. It's going to
give you all the details. It's fresh.
And it just happened. Yes, I everything
was in slow motion and I thought this
and he thought that and our eyes locked
and blah blah blah and all this detail,
right? But after
5 days, every time he meets somebody,
oh, I heard you were in a an accident.
What happened? Tell me what happened.
He's told the story a hundred times now.
What's going to happen by the end of
that? He's going to say, "Yeah, I was in
an accident, but alhamdulillah,
everything worked out." That's the same
narration,
isn't it? That's the same narration, but
one is more detailed and one is less.
This happens in the science of hadith,
right?
Zi is known for this. Zi
has narrations in almost every single
book ever written on hadith. He was one
of the imams of the entire dunya when it
came to narrating. Not only that, but he
died over the age of 80 and he narrated
all the way till the end. it. He did not
experience any sil
skew his narration. He narrated all the
way till the end. And so as Zui,
he has narrations that were taken from
him at the end of his life and he has
narrations that were taken from him when
he was 25 and 30 years old. Which one
which one of those narrations is more
detailed? the one that when he was
younger, we always look for the younger
students of Azuri,
the first students of Azori because that
is when he was most active. That is when
he was most detailed. That is when at at
the end of his life, he even said to
some of his students that came to take
narration from him, take from my
students.
He said, "I would direct you to some of
my students." And he directed to some of
his students who by this time were
muddled and said, "Because I am burnt
out with respect to narrating." He had
narrated for 50 years, 60 years.
And so this sometimes we would take the
narrations of his students over his own
narrations because they're less
detailed.
This narration of Omar is the one that's
used all the time. Even though it's not
as strong
narrationwise,
but it is far more detailed.
This is the most comprehensive account
of the incident. Whereas the narration
of Ebra is less detailed and there are
things missing. And this sentence is one
of those things missing in some of the
narrations of
we went usually we go just five or 10
minutes after fud but I think we you
know kind of enjoyed this little u u
side quest here that we did today. We
will end with that. We'll continue and
pick this up tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]